so it's up to Lake Charles Oh same old
same old
the county's complaining about it's
misleading the stockholders and blowing
the employee pensions and what a bunch
of babies me come on this is business
people writing and speaking of business
yeah that's good
take a powder
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Oh Mia says stop cruelly alright I'm
begging the close of his times I came
I'm detective Charles Stevens from the
Dade County Police Department I've got a
warrant here for your arrest a war achar
just cocaine trafficking and frankly I
fresh I don't know how to handle it what
I come in and turn myself in around
Thursday okay it's one o'clock good for
you oh no that's no good for me I got
some trim coming at 12:00 tell myself
and say between 2:00 and 6:00 thank you
so very much for your help and again I'm
sorry for the inconvenience I love you
too
so what am i charged with yeah like you
don't know you little bitch you do me a
favor and not smoke I'm allergic
oh hey I'm sorry Chuck when I do your
favor and put it out there for you huh
legal aid you're on sorry
you like my 14 case this week somebody
take a piss in here I pee
[Music]
I would like to compliment you gentlemen
on a very classy baller-ass spread with
Jesus that I've never even seen before
and my apologies for being late but I
got caught up with something I'm an
angular but you've done a lot of good
for the community oh I know man
Oh Thanksgiving I've been passing
turkeys out like Nino brown baby but
seriously we have to do something how
about you testify before a Senate
committee and spend two months at Club
fed when I get out can I steal traffic
rocks to the community absolutely not
yeah you're right ceiling rocks would be
wrong anyway he points the gun at us and
he tells his dog to SiC us was at that
point that I fired upon the canine and
we were able to subdue mr. Jeffries upon
further search of the mansion we were
able to locate this pure Colombian
heroin yeah wait a minute Your Honor I
don't know whose heroin that is but it
certainly is a mine that his wife
through her titties in my hand was weird
your honor you grabbed her titties I saw
you
before I sentence you is there anything
you'd like to say okay first of all
right that's enough you're the worst
kind of scum on the face of the earth
you're an animal
now filthy big-lipped beasts
congratulate the jury of your peers all
your possessions be seized immediately
by the court you will receive the
mandatory minimum of life in prison
plenty of time to lift weights and
convert to Islam get out of my sight you
sir
is it true you were a crack cocaine
dealer for seven years I plead the fifth
sir will you tell us about the cartels
you dealt with in your time as a crack
cocaine dealer no but I can tell you
that I plead the Physiol exactly how
much money did you earn in your time as
a crack cocaine dealer
[Laughter]
[Applause]
one two three four question did you
document that I think you need the same
we all forget afternoon I got your
sentence reduced to him
[Applause]